[Music]
blake shelton busts a move to lizzo's
track about damn time
it's literally shocking and it's
everything you could ever hope for and
more
my cool points are going up a little bit
with the kids on tuesday the country
singer posted this clip to tick tock
doing his best to get in on the viral
tick tock choreography to lizzo's hit
song
feeling fussy walking in my valencia
if you're not familiar with the dance it
originated with tiktok creator jaden
gomez and looks like this
[Music]
well didn't take long for the grammy
winner to see it so naturally she tried
it out poolside
in a minute i'm gonna need a sentimental
man a woman to pump me up feeling fussy
walking in my ballistics he's trying to
bring out the fat loss cause i give him
weight so
and has since performed the dance in
some pretty gorgeous places
now here's the teeth like the met gala
bathroom
feeling fussy walking in my opinion
i can't compete with that as for blake
well he gave it his all asking in the
caption did i do this right
in a minute i'ma need a sentimental man
a woman to pump me up
okay so yeah it was chaotic and kind of
all over the place but something tells
us lizza would approve good as hell
and while the 45 year old voice coach
may not want to quit his day job one
thing's for sure he's loving his new
role as step dad to gwen stefani's three
sons
i've learned a lot from her she's
definitely helped to calm me down the 52
year old no doubt singer and her
ex-husband gavin rossdale are parents to
15-year-old kingston 13 year old zuma
and eight-year-old apollo and during the
country radio seminar back in february
blake opened up about their blended
family quote i didn't know what i was
signing up for but i was all about
signing up for it and every day i've
fallen in love with the boys as much as
i do with gwen
couldn't be happier and that wasn't the
first time blake talked about being a
father figure here's what he said during
a radio interview back in 2021
i think it's very very serious you know
and but but also have a blast with it
i'm not gonna lie i don't take it so
serious that that i'm not enjoying this
time right because i really am
especially you know now that we're five
years into this thing i can't imagine my
life without these kids now
[Music]
you